Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192. David P, here's a you know,
speaking of awakenings, Tulsi Gabbard had
an awakening and went from the left to the
right. Dave Rubin had an awakening and went to
the left from the left to the right. Here's a
really good voicemail about the way these
awakenings differ when it's left to right
versus right to left. Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Hey, David, it's Tommy.
Have you ever noticed that when people shift
political sides, that if they go from the left
to the right, you're actually off the deep
end? Jesse Dallimore used to be a hardcore
conservative saying some terrible things now
on the left, and he makes a lot of sense and
he's intelligent and well informed. But then
you get people like Tulsi or Diamond and Silk
who used to be Democrats, and now they're
on the Republican side and they're just out
of their minds. Yeah. What's the deal with that?
Speaker 1: This is a very interesting observation.
Very, very interesting observation. I think
there's a couple reasons why going from left
to right leads to extremist lunacy. And going
from right to left is less commonly leading to
that kind of lunacy. By definition, I mean when we
talk about what is the right wing, the right wing,
generally speaking, is reactionary and it is fear
oriented. If you're only issue four, why you go
left to right is, you know, I realized instead of
a 37% top tax rate, we should really have like a
22% flat tax. That is not. Radical in the sense
that many of these other beliefs are radical. And
I'm not aware of anybody who went from left to
right because of a disagreement about what the
top tax rate should be. Generally speaking, the
reasons people go left to right are based in fear,
and they are extraordinarily reactionary. It's
stuff about, you know, they've been brainwashed
about transgender or they've become convinced
that anyone who gets an abortion is literally
a murderer, or that Democrats want to open the
floodgates with Mexican rapists who will rape
your daughters and sell drugs and whatever.
Right. They're what pulls people to the right
are. Ignorant and factually incorrect, but
also reactionary fear based ideologies. And
so the people susceptible to such a
drastic 180 because let's be honest,
if you're 16 and your political views change
significantly. You're just learning about what the
world is like. It's more believable when a 40 year
old man like Dave Rubin or a 40 year old woman
like Tulsi Gabbard do a 180. You have to wonder,
is it a grift? And this is just they're choosing
the most profitable character to play, or are they
so ignorant or susceptible to cult mentalities
that they are willing to be sucked in? By
definition, that is going to lead to people being
extreme. On the other hand, and I agree, people
like Jesse Dallimore, Jen Yuga, others who used
to be on the right and go to the left, they come
to the left for very non radical beliefs. Hey, you
know what I realized? We have the money to provide
everybody a basic level of a standard of living
with the taxes that we are collecting. I want
to be part of the movement that wants to do
that. It's not fear based, it's not reactionary,
it's actually empathetic. And so at its core,
I believe that that is the most important
reason why we see left to right awakenings
be extraordinarily extreme and right to left
awakenings not be that. Let me know your
thoughts. We have a great bonus show for you
today. Raphael Warnock is suing Georgia over
early voting restrictions for the December six
runoff. U.S. the U.S. has fined airlines the US
government has fined airlines seven and a
half million dollars for canceled flights.
We'll talk about when this happened and why it's
controversial and relevant. And Mitch McConnell
is facing a leadership challenge from Rick Scott
in the Senate. Where will this one go? We will
talk about it on the bonus show. You can sign
up and get instant access at joining tactical.